walk him to this video playing well
night off yeah I should have played you
for trying to test it if it's really
playing the night off okay we got the
Budapest gambit unfortunately I don't
have this quote ready from my for lady
about the guy from Budapest which Nigel
short gave in one of this if one of this
a comentary job that I found very funny
um something about a hairy hound from
Budapest was like that well okay um
while telling you about that I chose
them a sideline against this opening
with e3 and 94 that's not very well
known but a very decent line actually it
gets white very good control over me
five normally black plays with Bishop b4
check now on the move B form to get
something traded I mean 93 not sure I
want to allow my pawn structure to be
wrecked so Bishop before there will be
Bishop we should be for check that will
be Bishop d2 and the trade then the
Knight c3 Bishop e2 the very solid um
setup where black does not have much
active plane that's the the main idea
why this clamping on this d 5 square and
this is of course the main problem of
the whole Budapest gambit yeah it's not
like em it's it's that white takes the
pawn and end is happy with that but the
main problem of the Budapest is that the
structure with dnd pawn exchanged it
just very often leads to this type of
position where white will get a night to
d5 and yeah that's just not very
comfortable to live with a night on d
five and how do you get rid of the
knight on d5 yeah you can exchange it
let's say with the bishop from e 60 with
a night somewhere but then white we
probably take with the C porn which
leaves the open sea file open leaves an
opener which opens the C file and gets
pressure again c7 yeah and what can also
what's also possible is that leg is
playing on the night from c6 somewhere
and then c6 pawn to c6 to cover the d 5
squared expeller night yeah well this
weekend's d6 so this is some has always
been my main problem and objection to
the Budapest gambit that black moves
some is night like one two three times
and at the end he will get slightly
inferior structure however it is not a
structure that is in any way lost or
something for black get some just
slightly passive the Budapest is not a
very active opening actually I mean
there are some wacky lines but if y
chooses one office one of the main
continuations you quite often will end
up in this type of structure that we
have here white just ignores everything
and returns the porn and settles for
this kind of a slight slight edge and um
this is simply not much fun to play ok
so there should be six attacking on see
from yeah you all know I have fun have a
general choice I can take it which is
not bad getting the bishop and then gain
space with f4 that's not a bad idea I
can also play Knight f.2d five let's see
to d5 both move on quite an ideological
also be three is not
not bad at all hmm we are not easy to
decide they are all quite good probably
night x is six is the most incisive and
then FY it gives me a very nice central
control okay I'm going for be 3x it's
not it's not clear what what the best
continuation is and I might as well make
some more strengthening moves i can play
be three castles rook c1 d1 this kind of
moves and you know it's not so clear but
black is doing really he's six yeah sort
of probably just a waiting move I don't
really see a grand plan connected with
that I mean b5 is pretty much impossible
to play maybe maybe black create that we
would get some sort of situation where
all night f4 comes to d5 and the sea
night comes to be five which in fact
would have been no uncomfortable maybe
other than that I'm a six it's not clear
to me the purpose
yeah I think I'll just go with the nite
nite f.2d five plan that's very young
typical and straightforward way to play
I'm not playing this immediately because
I mean I can it's not not bad but what
can do some more prep moves like Roxy
one for example se1 it's just a typical
thing that with white having more space
um very often can afford to do more
preparation moves and approving moves
because they have more space and black
is maneuvering um on yeah unless ground
so the same and this is quite often
helpful to to not declare your
intentions so quickly okay so this is
interesting so should I play as planned
night here on is there something better
this also night takes c6 which is quite
tempting connected with that form f for
Bishop f3 is also very nice okay I'll
stay with this plan it's um certainly
okay Howie took that very quickly hmm
yeah well maybe he must in in the long
run but still okay um it is a totally
normal to take with the pawn of course
but as those check briefly if night XD
five is any good due to some concrete
reasons but i don't i don't think i
should do it just capturing with the
pawn is there is the descent is the
standard way to do it it opens up the
see file so that
seven is the target um I'm wondering
what about his play on the on the King
side is there something that I should
should do about it or should I just play
route see one and get on with with my
plane there is also something like f4
here f480 for grabbing the center which
isn't bad really not at all
yeah I think this is just a good good
way to play actually gaining the gaining
of this space I'll just take the center
if he goes to g4 I go h3 Knight f6
probably and deform this is just a very
nice center okay so I guess h3y am
taking on g4 is probably helping black
yeah guess so Knight f6 I'll play you
for I wonder if night h6 as an idea but
still efore it's not really am any help
so this is just a very nice Center and
he at the moment I cannot even a ticket
really let's say we'll see 67 d 6 is
hanging I guess I can take on c6 take d6
but ok what's what's my next step here
I'm very important to notice that the
Queen here it's not really well placed
or let's say it is a new my king but it
does not have many squares and what I'd
like to do is so it would be nice to get
in something like King age to g3 and
then push it away I wonder is it
possible maybe to to play for some sort
of Queen trap here
with let's say f5 ruger for this kind of
ideas yeah yeah this has thought about
but I thought that actually I'm not
rapping it okay I let's start with that
I mean I'm going to play this anyway no
use in spending time on every or
anything else I will ever play g3 yep I
want to bolster the center with the
coming Bishop f3 like g3 Queen retreats
Bishop f3 I just spotted a technical
idea if i play g3 and he goes to age 6 I
must be aware of the move Knight e5
because the Queen and e2 is unprotected
that's important actually muster I must
be alert they're not allowing any of
that okay
so Jeeva this is this is an important
point really g3 Queen Queen back to h6
and then this is 95 threat I think I
shouldn't play g3 right away but rather
prepare it for form for the moment the
point of the problem is g3 queen age 64
is hanging okay maybe just a queen move
like Queen d3 g3 queen age 6 23 else
could be could be an idea actually
yeah doing that and put them there is a
flight flight disharmony in my camp it's
really a three the case I'm a bit in
them slightly overextended here I just
hope that I didn't overlook anything I
need like one or two moves to sort of
make sure that there isn't something bad
happening in the center move like c6e I
could be critical really trying to
disturb my eye coordination okay yeah
now night c5 it's not really bothering
me that much I wonder
should I even play before I mean I can
do that before it as a five this might
be a problem this I also always must be
am aware of night x f4 possibilities
let's say be four a five a three a be 4i
before okay one look a one-night XF form
this could be could be a problem it's
probably not not really working but this
sort of thing could happen maybe just
Twiggy fun get out of this get out of 95
with the tempo and a five is not really
a good move on account of Bishop b5 i
believe i also have the idea to play
Bishop g4 at some point it could be a
plane a good way to to activate it ok so
now before
doing this now I can go to d3 and cover
cover you for reliably maybe c5
we had this type of position it is most
likely a good for white but it's not
easy because he always has this sort of
um this sort of counter playing at the
center often crimps are you connected
with technical tricks and sacrifices
like here every night h5 and just
checking on on f4 this could could
easily happen ok I don't I 194 it's not
really a threat I go to G to enter what
exactly has like accomplished maybe a
centralized first
he has a strange queen position is some
really quite remarkable but it shouldn't
be placed well but it's still um gifts
like some some sort of some sort of
counter chances here
how do i really make progress okay what
is he doing actually f5 is a seaplane
for f5 but this cannot be so great
actually f5 let's just improve a bit
here and five will mostly we can we can
black I can play a move like let's say
wiki two went if he takes it just
exposes flex position far more than it
does this post me any problem I think he
mostly needs to employ a sit and wait
strategy can maybe go really a four a
five I can I guy do that don't have so
much time
okay well it's it's really a nice space
advantage now
it would be excellent of course if he
would play that something like Queen f6
and allows me to drag queens this would
be very nice okay so he's going for this
this active push which I really didn't
believe in but let's see of course I
cannot take you one is singing but I
just thought that move like rookie to
intending look everyone I thought you
wouldn't need to take and this would
expose his position um even more maybe
I'm maybe this is not the case but like
e6 and so on looks very weak about here
yes Knight f6 mm-hmm now he's got an ID
of 6 here oh really my queen try this is
really nice for me that time I welcome
very much I have d5 as a weakness but
you cannot oh let's say witnesses wrong
word a potential weakness but i have a
huge space advantage and black really
has a hard time here my bishop is just
far stronger than the night zone will
ever be wait not not so quick g5 yeah I
can do that okay night h5 is not really
really helping a black in any way 359 h5
I briefly thought that a light h5 kingi
for rookie three years something but I
don't need to play King g4 can just
and ignore the night on h5 okay if I
take now here on age 7 this is g 6f 595
check hmm yeah that's probably playable
it's not it's not bad but there is there
is no reason to do it I can just play it
purely just just just strategically not
forcing anything yeah now both the
capture and h6 is good I wonder what's
the best really maybe the caption
location one this looks like looks like
the most convincing a key problem here
is that I have two against one porn here
which is a majority and his majority
four against three is completely dead
because NEC point is answered by the
capture and a six is dropping this is
why I went before I pond to a five
fixing those this some queenside pawns
okay so rook age six looks like oh wait
oh wait not so quick look you one I can
actually improve first him to like to go
to to e3 here or is there a better way
to do it night to g3 is also came all
night not to give force also nice ok
I'll do that
yeah it's hard to give him any advice
this is just quite a rotten position I
can't take it I guess I'll just take it
and quit enter 93 winning the pawn let's
just rinse the pawn king g6 rook h6
check yeah and then to two pesos that's
a bit much yeah this was quite quite
good quite good instructional material
let's say with Queen f6 this Queen trade
was really almost losing I believe it
leads to very very one-sided endgame
that he needed to to keep Queens on
black resign really had at almost any
cost this is yeah you you saw how
quickly it went downhill after the Queen
trade in this position I think I mean
white white should be better in any case
but it's not decisive I sent me a
well-played thanks um yeah it should be
better in any case but I thought you
should take it really end and go from
there but okay well it's it's not it's
not very nice light is coming to g5 I
understand yeah it's quite funny that
the computer also wants to play Queen f6
but yeah maybe maybe it's just a matter
of I thought this actually this this is
this kind of this kind of position yeah
it should be better for white but well I
was just thinking that Queen f6 is
totally one-sided
after this i mean i'm almost the pawn up
in in a way because as mentioned the the
queenside points by blackjack that
totally fixed he cannot move any of this
and i push the three against two
majority supported by them good Bishop
p.m. black is completely without any
sort of counter play yeah here I could
have taken I could have taken I mean as
i mentioned i thought well i don't need
to rush things but this is probably just
just just possible yeah i can do that
it's not not a problem at all okay well
but this is it's really not much of a
difference i mean this is totally
one-sided rook is coming to h6 sent it's
just like I'm completely controlling the
night on d7 for example it cannot move
in any way to entrant here but now the
next piece is coming and while this
didn't help the night f5 move but what
is black going to do look at this can
you can do all kinds of stuff yeah king
here and so on it's just like a one-way
street like you will never ever do
anything active here yeah this is some
kind of very typical challenge I'm
fairly typical of this structure in the
in the Budapest as I mentioned well you
put something on d5 and quite often you
get this kind of very comfortable
strategically advantageous position in
the center all right I hope you enjoyed
it pretty interesting I think thanks for
watching